direction le maille d'au présent et la
route du tvlave de spots de montagne
investi par de nouveaux engins roulants
les trik un sport né au Brésil il y a 8
ans véritable phénomène aux États-Unis
et introduit à la Réunion depuis 3
ans c'est le TR est une discipline qui a
été inventée par un Brésilien qui le
brevet été racheté à un moment donné par
les Américains puisque eux sont sont
intéressé par tout ce qui est sport de
glisse et qui peuvent diffuser en masse
alors l'intérêt de la pratique du du
trike et surtout centré sur le le le
développement du bien-être et de plein
air les Américains appellent cette
machine à juste titre la fitness machine
donc on va solliciter certains groupes
musculaires chacun à son niveau qu'on
soit petit puisque c'est un produit qui
peuvent être utilisé à partir de 6 ans
jusque adultes senior donc ça convient à
différents types de la famille et on
peut aussi partir sur de l'extrême en
fristal et également sur de la descente
pure
les possibilités du track se font
surtout sur la route et sur le plat on
peut également remonter certains faux
plats avec mais on peut également
l'utiliser dans certains cas sur du du
chemin proche d'une discipline de sport
de glisse type le le ski notamment dans
dans la descente et sur le plat on
s'approche plus à des séances un petit
peu de fitness de step puisqu'on
sollicite plutôt la partie basse du
musculairement donc chacun peut utiliser
l'énergie de de de ses muscles à sa
convenance alors le track est très
facile d'utilisation euh déjà on a trois
points dessus donc avec trois roues et
ce qui facilite les choses dessus fa
appelle à l'équilibre et généralement au
bout d'un quart d'heure on a une
initiation assez complète de de dessus
pour se lancer sur les chemins et sur
l'aventure prè descente qui a été faite
sur un terrain je dirais un chemin avec
qui était herbeux avec des des ornières
où on avait une technique de glise qui
s'apparentait un petit peu à du trial et
une deuxième partie qui était faite sur
un un chemin beaucoup plus plat mais
avec des cailloux où on avait une glisse
beaucoup plus proche de ce qui peut être
réalisé je dirais en
ski
il est possible de louer le le trke
avant de l'acheter ce qui permet de
pouvoir bien définir un petit peu son
son projet en terme d'utilisation ce qui
correspond le mieux à ses
affinités